welcome everyone thanks for joining us
it is a very busy Friday a lot of news
to get to so let's get started here's
tonight's top story
no miss shallow this song that I wrote
with it though
all the two ever want is for art to
touch people's hearts it's the song that
turned Lady gaga
into an Oscar winner but now she's being
accused of stealing the melody and a
lawsuit may be coming the legal threat
comes from this unknown singer
songwriter named Steve Ronson
hey guys Steve here again trying to be
helpful he claims a few notes from
shallow are ripped from his own 2012
songs almost here are the tracks back to
back in a statement to ET Ronson says he
just wants to quote get to the bottom of
this to investigate any possible
infringement according to our source
Ronson is asking for a multi-million
dollar settlement in a move Gaga's legal
team describes as a quote
brazen shakedown her attorney tells DT
if a students file quote Lady Gaga will
fight it vigorously and will prevail
all this comes on the heels of Katy
Perry being ordered to pay up after a
jury found her liable for copyright
infringement for the 2013 hit Dark Horse
the judgment 2.7 eight million dollars
five million dollars is what Robin
Thicke ultimately paid Marvin Gaye's
estate for his 2015 bloodlines copyright
infringement judgment you just never
know what's going to happen but back to
Gaga her attorney tells ET she is
determined to stand up on behalf of
quote successful artists who find
themselves on the receiving end of
opportunistic claims such as this
[Music]
[Applause]